if you died a horrible death and came
back to life what would you do you've
returned from beyond the grave and will
be forced to hunt horrifying aliens in
countless death games and you can't
escape i'm going to break down the
mistakes made what you should do and how
to beat the death games in gantz this
kid here has no idea that he is about to
die kay over here is just another
japanese youngster hoping to find a job
when down in the subway he notices
someone familiar in the distance in
between the crowds kate notices this kid
kato an old school friend he hasn't seen
in years and he and kato wait for the
incoming train little do they both know
that this train will be the death of
both of them suddenly someone near kato
collapses onto the train tracks and
goody two-shoes kato rushes down like a
knight in shining armor to save him but
he can't get up and the train is coming
k looks on in sheer awkwardness as he
tries to avoid being spotted but tough
[ __ ] cause kato then spots k prompting
an awkward staring contest for a few
seconds as he watches kato save this man
from certain death but then the roaring
engine of japan's metro comes charging
down the tracks and kato can't get up so
kaye quickly goes to help poor kato but
in the process gets dragged down by
accident onto the tracks until both of
their lips meet to kiss the train dead
okay this was a brutal mistake these
kids waited around for too long and
that's what got them killed considering
that they're standing on train tracks
they should be actively trying to escape
as soon as possible instead of sitting
around and talking about what to do
their very first mistake was not
realizing that there's an emergency
compartment hidden under the tracks of
every train station in the city of tokyo
even if they were unable to climb
because of how difficult it is to get up
we can clearly see that there's a small
gap that two people could fit in right
to the side of them look it's
understandable that they might be
freaking the hell out because of this
high-speed train coming towards them but
let's stay calm folks we need to stay
alive tokyo has a high rate of train
related deaths in the past few decades
because of this safety measures have
been enhanced by the metropolitan
authorities to make sure these incidents
become a few and far between thing
however there is another way that we
could escape this situation relatively
unscathed if we're willing to sacrifice
our new old friend here since he brought
me into this situation i would quickly
try to convince him to let me use him as
a human trampoline to push me up into
the air and over the train ledge now
whether or not our friend here is going
to survive is a tricky question but
that's not our problem anymore now is it
kay and kato suddenly wake up to find
themselves in a barren room washed over
by the white lights of this seemingly
nefarious apartment and they're not
alone and in front of them says other
confused and terrified individuals who
also don't know how they got there the
two boys then turn around to find an
unknown black sphere in the middle of
the room they then investigate the rest
of the apartment to find themselves
trapped inside with all the doors and
windows locked kay and kato try and
piece the puzzles together and they
realize that they aren't the only ones
who seemingly just died because everyone
else in this room came here after
suddenly dying in random ways and no one
knows anything just then this black
sphere interrupts everyone by emitting
what appears to be the body of a young
girl as she seemingly fizzles into
existence out of thin air and she plops
right onto k's lap freaking him the hell
out and not in a good way the room joins
in on the puzzled reactions as this girl
wakes up and we find out her name is
kishimoto but just then a sinister
anthem begins to roar from within the
black sphere captivating everyone in the
room digital text then begins to appear
on the sphere that reads to everyone in
this room that their old lives are gone
and that this strange black orb will
decide how to use their new lives and
then it begins to display a horrifying
image of a strange beast that this
sphere wants them to go kill right
before its interior pops open displaying
an array of high-tech weaponry along
with a strange sleeping man inside the
sphere itself and inside along with all
of this cases containing suits with all
of their names on it and so the group
with more questions than answers begins
suiting up and kay notices that this one
kid creepy face is seemingly already
suited up and seems way more calm than
the rest of the group here but he
doesn't have time to dwell on it because
this guy starts fizzling out of
existence and the rest of the gang
begins freaking out one by one following
this guy's lead as they all disappear
from existence right into this random
alley however this creepy-haired kid
finally spills the beans and tells
everyone that they all got here through
hypnosis and that he's the son of the
producer of this holographic tv show
that they're all in saying that if they
complete the mission they'll all win 100
million yen as a reward but something is
off and kay doesn't trust him for one
second
okay something isn't right here there's
no way that this creepy-faced kid what
he's saying is true because up until now
the only vr type technology out there
for public use has been through
holographic capabilities represented
through modern ar what we saw with
princess leia as a holograph back in
star wars is largely something out of
the realm of modern science still which
means there's no way that humans can
produce the perception of holograms in
standard non-modified atmospheric air
without the presence of some type of
headset even the famous hologram of
tupac shakur on the stage was in fact
not a hologram but was actually a 2d
image projected onto an angled piece of
glass which was then projected onto a
transparent screen along with the help
of a projector the point is that we're
out in the open and we ain't wearing no
google glasses which means there's no
possible way that this creepy-faced kid
what he's saying is in fact true but
let's say that it was that that means
whoever put us in this virtual reality
clearly has the technological and
financial capabilities to put us in a
virtual world where we cannot trust our
own senses and that is terrifying the
one thing that we can take away from all
of this is creepyface kid himself
because when we arrived into that room
he was the only one who was already
suited up and the only one who had any
explanation at all as to what was going
on and he's the only one who exhibited
the confidence to spew that lie if this
really was a competitive match with 100
million yen on the line then why would
he give away the objective willy-nilly
why would he say anything at all saying
nothing would have given him a better
shot at winning the money right
something is going on with creepyface
kid because he seems to know something
that we don't which is why i would keep
a close eye on him and his actions
because us looking out for him actually
means that we are looking after
ourselves in the process the group of
lost players then noticed something
strange in the distance watching them
something green and not quite human and
also holding a green onion creepy face
kid then points out that that little
green abomination is the target and that
whoever catches it within 20 minutes
wins causing the entire group of money
hungry players to hunt down their target
the group catches up to this strange
green alien and it begins to offer its
green onion to the group but they don't
give two shits about no green onions as
they lick their lips in anticipation
while they prepare to kill this creature
but suddenly this sneaky green little
bastard slips away right over the fence
as he jumps over this fence like a
superhuman forcing the gang to continue
the chase following him down the street
right past our unbothered main heroes
and right into this dingy garage the
group of players have finally managed to
corner this green onion knowing that
their actions within the next few
minutes will change their lives and
their fate forever the green onion head
of an alien begs to be spared as it
offers its green onions again as a token
of friendship but it's no use these
players want blood and they ready their
arcade looking weaponry with no idea how
it works and this dude takes a shot and
nothing the gang wonders if their
weapons are broken but then suddenly an
explosion erupts from within the green
alien as his entire arm is blasted off
of his body angering this little green
alien and making it dangerously handsy
with our players causing the group to
get pissed off as this time they all
fire simultaneously at this monster
causing his body to savagely get blasted
apart as its guts spray all over the
entire room and this guy this sicko he
likes what he sees and fires another
shot before kato angrily tries to stop
him but suddenly their problems get
about seven feet bigger because right
behind them is another alien and this
one looks like the green onion's older
brother and he looks pissed the money
hungry gang of idiots stand in front of
it paralyzed as hell and this terrifying
monster towers over our unlucky players
as they prepare to battle or die but
this yakuza wannabe is too much of a
stud to give a [ __ ] and decides to
confront this beast head on suddenly he
hears a swift crack erupt from below him
and he looks down to his leg in sheer
horror shock quickly sets in for our
gangster stud as he collapses in front
of this monster right as the beast grabs
his skull and lifts him up into the air
the group begins to freak out right as
they blast off a couple of rounds at
this horrifying monster but they can't
land a single shot as this creature uses
yakuza stud as a meat shield blocking
all of the shots with terrifying ease
okay this is terrifying but in all
fairness they should have seen the signs
if we follow the fact that these matches
categorize themselves as games then that
means that these death games would
likely follow some semblance of game
structure such as the inclusion of boss
battles found within almost all types of
games in various genres with the
structure of boss battles usually being
found at the end of each sector just as
when the intensity within the game rises
to its peak followed by the defeat of
the boss at which the intensity will
usually die down for a bit after hunting
the little green onion alien it was
clearly an easy enemy to defeat and it's
no wonder that the first enemy for the
first game for our players was the
easiest one meaning that the gang could
have stopped to maybe think about this
for a minute that this was a game how
many enemies would they have to hunt
before the difficulty went up and how
many enemies would they have to hunt
within the first game before harder more
terrifying enemies show up this is why i
would have stopped and maybe would have
tried to capture the little green onion
and then figure out our next step and i
would have been as hasty as they were
and from the looks of his cute little
sweet weird face this little green onion
baby was clearly a child which means
that it's safe to say that what we're up
against now would be the parent or at
least a really pissed off older relative
of our now deceased onion friend because
what the gang is up against now is a
more mature green onion alien and from
what we have just witnessed this
creature has the ability to produce
razor-sharp claws from his hands that
can obviously maim and kill people right
here on the spot and this creature's
offensive abilities means that we're
better off fighting him in an open space
and not within an enclosed area such as
this one this thing is currently
carrying one of the other players and
using him as a freaking meat shield of
shorts and that's awesome which means
that we have no way of stopping him
right here so if i'm k i'd simply use
glasses guy in front of me as my own
shield of meat and push him right at
this angry green onion creature as a
distraction before running behind him
and out of the garage entirely once out
in the open we'll have a better shot at
killing him without having to be so
ridiculously close to his claws and
besides this guy has shown himself to be
a rather physically weak individual so i
say for the greater good he should do
the noble cause of sacrificing himself
for us right his death is the best bet
in getting out of here alive the yakuza
wannabe guy suddenly explodes sending
his tender organs everywhere this alien
monster is out for blood and everyone
here is about to die a brutal death and
they know it elsewhere kay walks nearby
as he hears the screams of petrified
victims causing him to check out the
same garage as our alien friend just as
a blood-covered kato stands there
practically [ __ ] bricks corpses of
some of the players encircle this green
demon as it slowly pushes them out into
the alley ready to spill more blood but
then in comes kishimoto flying wild and
taking shots whipping this horrifying
monster right into the concrete slab
nearby but she ain't prepared for [ __ ]
as her corner eye notices the
corpse-filled garage in front of her
along with a paralyzed and stricken kato
just then this green beast rises back up
taking sudden swings at kishimoto and k
making kishimoto realize that her suit
protected her and making kaye realize
that the suit is the key to surviving k
whips the green monster on the head to
no effect pissing off our alien friend
who roars just as k prepares to die
himself though suddenly the snapping and
whipping of an alien round pierces
through the air and ties up our alien
friend right as creepy face guy fizzles
into existence thanks to his
invisibility suit i want one looks like
that little [ __ ] was hiding and watching
the whole time creepyface kid then
offers 4k to kill this captured monster
but he's too much of a goody two-shoes
to take the shot and chokes forcing
creepyface kid to handle it himself and
he shoots this beast right in front of
them causing the game to suddenly end
and the group appears back in the same
room as before and there creepyface kid
divulges the name of the mysterious
black sphere gantz just then this
glasses guy comes back to join the group
showing us that no matter how far on the
brink of death someone is if they
survive the round they'll come back
fully healed after the game ends gantz
then relays score points for everybody
on the screen as k demands to know what
is going on forcing creepy face kid to
reveal that they are here to stop an
alien invasion from attacking earth and
that except for him this is the first
time that he's seen anyone survive more
than a single round within gantz and
this news freaks k out who picks up his
pistol and directs it right a creepy
kid's sweet face before kay suddenly is
teleported back to his room almost as if
it were a dream holy crap this is insane
but here's the thing we don't know if
what just happened was real because like
i said technology up until this point
that we know of has now developed tech
with the capabilities to make everything
around us into a perfect realistic star
trek hollow holodeck and to add to that
we just woke up in our bed with no
memory of how we got here nor do we
remember how we got to that empty room
either so really we're at a loss for
words and throwing aliens into the mix
which means there's a pretty good chance
that whatever happened was just a
terrifying dream but here's the thing
this wasn't any old dream because we saw
a long-lost friend from school who we
haven't seen in years which is why to be
safe i would follow up on all possible
leads just on the off chance that
whatever happened really did happen
because how many times have we heard of
alien encounters in the news since this
stuff started being reported back in the
60s a lot which means statistically it's
not crazy to think that we could be one
of the few people who's just experienced
an alien encounter now if this is the
case then our only chance of finding out
what's going on will be making sure our
timeline within the last 24 hours
matches that of the people within the
game if we can find them in real life
because if we can find even one of our
team mates this will clear up everything
in minutes because they'll either think
we're nuts or will probably give us a
hug and be glad that someone else
actually believes their crazy alien
hunting story in this instance we have
our long-lost friend kato who k mentions
that they went to the same school
together so in this case i would start
there and begin by finding him either
through the school's directory or by
going online and using social media to
identify the locations of his hangouts
and all of this will give us a better
shot at finding him before the next game
starts if we start looking right now k
wakes up confused as all hell not
knowing what in the world just happened
but he knows someone who might have some
answers his old buddy kato forcing kay
to comb through the japanese phone books
looking for his long lost friend and his
address finding the winning ticket k
rushes out hoping that whatever is going
on has ended for good kay later reaches
kato's old address but realizes that
nothing is there then again kato's
address is from 10 years ago making kay
to be even more stumped and lost for
answers than ever forcing him to head
back home in idiotic shame but on the
way there he passes by an alley and
notices something horrifying it's the
same alley from last night and the same
dingy garage from before except its
bloodstained walls are nowhere to be
seen which means that whatever happened
last night could have been real but
kaye's crusher is [ __ ] is real as he
bumps into her right then and there and
he spots her gant suit showing from her
bag along with kato's jacket that she
wore back in gantz making it even harder
to ignore that what happened last night
was real but with no blood-stained walls
and no kato the gang disappointedly
calls it a day and kay prepares to walk
kishimoto home like a gentleman right
but kishimoto then asks the most
horrifying thing ever most horrifyingly
awesome thing ever that is as she asks
kate if she can stay with him tonight as
she has no place to live thanks to an
angry ex-boyfriend who just kicked her
out making his lost case gain as he
tries to play it cool and the duo heads
back to his apartment where some very
expected g-rated action happens as in
nothing happens as in kishimoto steals
k's bed before the tired and confused
duo pass out in awkward silence bummer
but on the other side of town kato wakes
up from a nightmare just before telling
his little brother to head back to bed
not realizing that whatever happened to
him and the others is about to happen
again because just then half of his face
begins disappearing just as before with
his body fizzling back out and right
back into the same room as everyone else
right into the room with gans as k kato
and kishimoto look on and cheer terror
at each other and all of the newcomers
in the room including a kid his grandma
glasses guy and some other random people
looking just as confused as ken kato
were when they first died along with
creepy face kid in the background
looking just as predatory as ever okay
this confirms the fact that this is in
fact happening folks and that this is
not a dream which means we are screwed
and judging from the last time we have
less than four minutes until we get
teleported into the next horrifying
death game but this time we're not the
confused ones because we have this due
to grandma her kid i mean we have some
real meat shield options but let's be
honest creepy kid won't tell on us and
he's really the only one from the first
game who knows what's going on which
means for now he's on the same side as
us and the new people in this room don't
look too smart either
suckers so i would pull a page right out
of this bastard's book and tell the rest
of the players that we're in a
holographic game funded by
neuroscientists to test out the concept
of fear using high-tech implanted chips
and that whatever we're about to see
within the game isn't real whatever pain
we experience isn't real however real it
might feel remember i don't think these
people are that smart so this flat out
lie i think should be just enough to do
its job the fact is is that we can use
these people's gullibility i'm looking
at this grandma to our advantage and
make them act as our unofficial meat
shields that i talked about earlier once
the game begins i'd also begin to keep
these people distracted and keep our
gant suits tucked inside our briefcases
until the game begins this way when we
put our suits on the other people won't
have a suit to worry about since they
won't have one because we need these
noobs powerless and dependent on us
because the last thing we need for them
is to get pissed off at us and start
taking superhuman pot shots at us in
their gantt suits because screw that
idea i don't like it creepy face kid
then sadistically says that no matter
where they are in the world gans will
always find them and bring them back to
play more death games the gang looks in
sheer horror while one by one they begin
to disappear and kay and kato quickly
try to arm the rest of the group while
this grandma and kid get separated upon
a rival into this death arena and end up
bumping into this horrifying robotic
alien and it walks right up to these
innocent folks and opens its mouth
revealing a bright light from within as
it prepares to murder them right here
and now all the while this innocent
child and sweet old lady look on in
sheer helplessness nearby kaye finally
appears into the arena parking lot but
comes face to face with something
straight out of a horror film it's the
grandma and boy or their corpses who lay
there like abandoned ragdolls dead on
the street it's horrifying just then he
sees the infamous murder creature
standing opposite of him ready for a
showdown to the death standing opposite
of k is his next target the tanaka alien
okay i guess they made this monster
different than the one in the anime
which we also did a video on which you
can check out up in the corner here but
this robot in the anime is actually a
suit that houses the most insane thing
ever inside a bird as in an actual alien
bird known as the tanaka alien a race of
freakishly huge birds that use that suit
in front of us right here as some sort
of a spacesuit to be able to breathe
inside earth's atmosphere like no joke
there's an actual bird inside of that
robot people i'm not kidding and while
this dude looks a little different than
in the anime i'm willing to bet that his
suit works pretty much the same way and
this type of info is invaluable to us
because this means that without their
suit they're screwed however their main
attack is a high-pitched supersonic
blast emitted from their mouth that can
cause hemorrhaging from the eyes and
ears as in serious bleeding and while we
do have firearms they likely wouldn't do
so well at long range due to this alien
creature's agility and ability to dodge
attacks at high speeds this means that
our best bet would be to use the team
that we have and actually use them and
not for just meat shields darn it in
order to actually go up against this
creature from different angles if i'm k
i would advise all members to go at this
beast from all angles simultaneously
while he tries to take us all down and
in doing so we'll be able to keep it
distracted until one of us eventually
closes the gap and gets right in its
face because remember without their suit
the alien from within can't last very
long in our environment and it will then
die shortly thereafter this means using
our suits hiding abilities we could
superhumanly squeeze the [ __ ] right out
of it until the suit gets damaged enough
to the point where the creature will
have to exit the suit of its own sheer
will because let's be honest who would
want to stay inside a crushed astronaut
suit not me so let us use that to our
advantage k like a freaking idiot just
stands there and fires a shot at the
tanaka alien while pretty much receiving
this alien's blast head on suddenly the
tanaka aliens face shakes at a
frightening speed and then launches a
blast into nothing until it connects
with creepy face kid in the distance the
tanaka alien knew where he was despite
him being invisible the tanaka alien
rises fast into the air and dive bombs
headfirst into creepy face kid plunging
him down into the basement parking lot
and he proceeds to beat the [ __ ] out of
him while the rest of the gang fizzles
into existence but kato is a stud cut
above the rest and jumps down onto the
tanaka alien right before it kills
creepyface kid and kato squeezes the
life out of the alien getting some help
from his super suit causing this
creature to go down for the count k
rushes over to creepyface kid as his
shattered voice mutters for k to save
him when he eventually gets 100 points
but k is no clue as to what the hell
he's talking about as creepy face kid
finally kicks the bucket suddenly
however the tanaka alien blasts up with
more gusto than a bull on red bull
knocking kato back as he tries to take
pot shots at kishimoto kato quickly
swings back around to protect her and
gets the [ __ ] kicked out of him instead
with kato himself getting forced
mouth-to-mouth and is about to have his
head blasted off right before kishimoto
knocks this alien's face off with some
last-minute sultry moves but this
creature is too damn powerful and knocks
everyone back just as k learns how to
use his super suit and gives this alien
a taste of his own medicine beating the
alien down into a car as the two
intimately duke it out until the alien
grabs case face and is about to blast
his face off when kay suddenly grabs his
gun from the car floor and shoves his
gun into the alien's mouth and fires
causing a sudden explosion to erupt from
the car itself killing the alien and
winning the game as the gang and k
nearly on the brink of death appear back
in front of gantz good as new but he
doesn't have time to play around and
demands to know what happens when
someone gets 100 points and that's when
gatz shows him the 100 point menu
showing two options for players to
choose from that list should they ever
reach that many points option one gain
your freedom option two bring someone
who died from within a dance game back
to life just as everyone then teleports
back to their old lives however this
time kay already wearing his suit has
some ideas and begins training with his
suit in the real world vowing to get
stronger for the next time when the next
game inevitably summons him back
elsewhere a kato shack of an apartment
he sees on the news that the explosion
that happened last night in gantz was
real and he quickly realizes that the
world is going to [ __ ] that it's up to
him and gantz to stop them and our three
heroes ready themselves mentally for the
next game and sure enough the next game
arrives and summons them accordingly
this time with fresh meat as our veteran
trio head into the game with their wits
about them and gantz gives them their
next target the gang gets teleported to
this place a sinister looking museum
just as this new pops off on one statue
causing the one right next to it to come
to life okay this is insanely horrifying
for this encounter we lack any prior
knowledge on what the hell this thing is
but unlike the tanaka alien or the green
onion alien this thing seems to lack the
capabilities to perform any longer range
attacks on us whether that be in the
form of energy blasts or retractable
claws like our good old green onion
friend here which means we may have a
chance and in this case i would continue
to stay out in the open so we don't get
trapped in the corner of the wall where
this monster's brute force strength
would surely have an upper hand on us
keeping a distance will be key for us to
have the upper hand from the looks of
things at least one of them has
something more than the standard gans x
gun which is a small handgun sized
weapon that does better at close range
encounters this guy yeah this one is
carrying an x shotgun which is similar
to the x gun in almost every way except
when it comes to long distance it has a
higher accuracy that can be fired in the
hands of someone proficient from over
one kilometer away this is why we need
to get this guy out from under this
creature's legs literally and get him to
a safe distance from which he'll be able
to take a shot more effectively because
a creature of this size makes me suspect
that a simple shot from the x-gun won't
do much if i was kerokato i'd snag the
x-gun shotgun for myself and order the
rest of my comrades to begin distracting
this beast with additional suppressing
fire to keep him at bay while we ready
up our shot from a safer distance the
whole gang is dead as everyone freaks
the hell out and scurries like rats
desperate to survive just one more day
with this monk and this chick heading
inside leaving k pretty much all by
himself against this ugly beast right as
this monster tries taking shots at
anyone he can get his hands on and it's
about to stomp on this one dude until
his whole leg explodes thanks to some
good old alien rounds provided by kato
just as k readies his badass pistol now
turns rifle right at this abomination
causing it to explode right here and now
but kishimoto doesn't have time to
celebrate as she then watches cocky k
declare to kato that he's pretty much
the bigger chat and can handle
everything that gats throws at him but
something is not right because they
haven't teleported back to gantz yet
which means this death game isn't over
not by a long shot and they're so right
because what awaits them is truly more
horrifying than they could ever imagine
and it will cost them everyone back
inside this scared monk hides from the
action outside and thinks he's safe but
no one is safe in ghance just as he
notices something strange from across
this statute-filled room but he just
thinks he's hallucinating as he
continues to pray to his gods not
realizing that he's about to face a god
right now he then opens his eyes again
and notices the most horrifying thing
standing right in front of him the true
enemy of gats this bronzed beast and
right outside those horrifying doors
stands this girl as she tries to see
from inside if the horrors outside are
over and she too gets the bright idea to
go inside that treacherous room closing
the doors on what might as well be her
valuable life back outside kane kato
stand there as they try to figure out
what the hell is going on just as they
suddenly hear the opening of the museum
door revealing a battle torn player as
she collapses in front of them k then
realizes that their horror show isn't
over as he and the gang cautiously comb
through the insides of this sinister
atrium aiming their sights on the site
of their final battleground of which
they slowly enter only to see the
horrifying corpse of the monk from
earlier or what's left of him causing
their fight-or-flight instincts to go
off from within their gut knowing what
we know that they're screwed right as
kato realizes what he sees a thousand
armed buddha bringing kay to his knees
and disarming him in an instant okay
this is a little crazy and kind of
horrifying at the same time especially
when we consider that unlike the rest of
the aliens that we fought so far we
don't know anything about this creature
except for whatever few visual
similarities that it shares with the
actual thousand armed deity in real life
known in himalayan buddhism but that's
pretty much where the similarities end
folks and with no other information
given to us by gantz we're kind of at a
huge disadvantage however gans is no
idiot presumably and so we should trust
that the weapons it's provided for us
should work if we can actually land a
shot because from what we've seen this
alien has superhuman speed and is lethal
at close distances which it doesn't take
a genius to figure out i mean have you
seen how many arms it's got at this
point what we can use is the power of
teamwork or more specifically teamwork
that proceeds into backstabbing because
in reality it's every man for himself
and so if i was k i would lie to kato
and tell him to distract this alien with
his sword at close range along with
kishimoto while i try and line up to
take a shot from a distance now what's
brilliant about this and different from
before is that with kato fighting
alongside with kishimoto from what we
know of how kishimoto feels for kato
judging from her love stares throughout
the entire movie this would make her a
lot more susceptible to making sure that
she protects kato at all costs and if he
gets cut which he probably will let's be
honest then that'll make kishimoto all
the more inclined to go crazy and fight
this alien even harder that is the power
of love my friends and this is what will
make her the perfect distraction to keep
this alien busy while we take it out
from a distance and if they die at the
end meh at least we live this
thousand-armed god then lays down
attrition with a bombardment of sword
upon a disarmed k as a cross to safety
but not without some serious scratches
leaving him crippled enough to tag team
in kato but not before a sweet bro
session happens between the two helping
to fuel the rage within kato and have
him rise back up to tackle this monster
head on entering a now empty room with
the nothing but some clues left behind
as to where this horrifying monster
could be suddenly it pops up from behind
him slashing the glass in front of k and
almost taking an eye out in the process
and now the two stand ready to duel mano
amano the thousand armed buddha that
lets out a code whisper of anger-filled
words saying they killed its friends and
that it will have revenge upon all of
them sending a shiver up and down kato's
arm because he knows what he's in for
just then a loud explosion erupts in
front of kate as the monster disappears
right as kishimoto stands with her
smoking gun yelling for k to run just as
she gets knocked down and disarmed by
the monster the brawn beast approaches
her menacingly but that's when kato
charges up with his sword like kirito
with his overpowered dual blades sending
in precision strikes like a surgeon
until he gets pummeled back hard right
then the bronze monster charges up to
finish the job forcing kishimoto to
sacrifice herself for kato and her limp
corpse falls down to the floor causing a
feeble kato to hold her closely and view
the obligatory attempted love before
dying scene just as she kicks the bucket
in his arms but this cutesy wannabe
couple is enough to fuel kato with
enough hutzpa to overcome his pain and
he charges back in to fight this demon a
final time and a final time it proves to
be for him just as he gets stabbed right
in front of a helpless k throwing his
corpse in front of his best friend
making this the last straw for k the
fibo k then grabs his fallen comrade
sword and attacks this creature for a
final time but it's hopeless as it sends
k back yet again making him take a
different approach like with this gun
making him jump in the air as the
buddha's swords graze his skin and
superman jumps over this thing and gi
joe rolls right over onto his weapon as
he rolls and arms himself with his
sights set on this thousand-armed demon
it's done and kaye fires off a round but
this thing deflects it resulting in an
explosion and this creature reveals a
trump card up its sleeve this mini
statue of itself as this buddha demon
drops it right down past k as he lays
witness to what horrifyingly happens
next this little statue begins to twitch
as its little form begins to expand into
something straight out of a horror movie
forcing k to get some distance from it
but it's no use the other players
outside look in awe and terror as this
monster practically ascends from hell
forcing out much tinier k to scurry back
a smidge as he prepares for the final
showdown okay talk about our worst
nightmare and add to that our worst
enemy is now a billion times larger and
at this point we have little option
because we clearly can't outrun this
thing but our best bet at this point
would be again say it with me now folks
teamwork makes the dream work time is
ticking and a ton of our teammates are
dead but we do have a few meat shields i
mean friends left alive as we can
clearly see so i would order these two
players to run within the museum itself
and make this godzilla alien chase them
throughout the entire structure
destroying everything in its sight as it
tries to kill them then while it does
this if i'm k i would try to get up
close and personal to this giant alien's
head for a closer shot at it because i
don't see any x shotgun anywhere anymore
which means all we got left is our
little x gun and we risk that alien
blocking our shots with its hands if we
try and fire it from too far of a
distance this is why we need to get in
close this gigantic statue then hulk
smashes k causing him to run for his
life like a squirrel to his nut and he
sees in the distance kato he's alive and
they bro telepathy one another to come
up with a last minute plan having kay
here run up into the buddha's fists as
kato fires his gun causing kay to slip
out and continue running forward up this
monster's body getting head-butted back
down and coming face to face with this
horrifying creature just in case
superman jumps right into the monster's
mouth before he blasts this beast's
insides and it explodes everywhere right
then k comes out of the storm like a
stud and sees his best friend right
before he too kicks the bucket causing
kate to suddenly appear back in the room
with gats and the rest of the survivors
with kay then realizing that his best
friend isn't back yet and his score
tally tops off at 13 just as gas reveals
that his fallen bro is trapped within
cats but you don't simply stop being a
bro and so with 87 more points to go kay
then vows to fight as many alien
bastards as it'll take to rescue his
best bro and maybe kishimoto one day hey
guys thank you so much for watching our
video don't forget to like subscribe let
us know what you liked what you didn't
like and also don't forget to check out
our how to be playlist and our social
media